surprise ou attendu la décision de
guillaume pelletier de rejoindre les
rangs d'eric zemmour a fait l'effet
d'une bombe dans le milieu politique
locale l'ex numéro deux des républicains
ne siège plus dans la majorité du
conseil départemental du loir et cher
les réactions des élus ne se sont pas
fait attendre florent clavel j'ai pris
la décision de soutenir le seul candidat
de la droite le seul candidat du rpr je
rejoins eric zemmour c'est par cette
déclaration sur europe 1 que guillaume
pelletier a officialisé hier son soutien
au candidat à la présidentielle ou
tonnerre au conseil départemental du
loir-et-cher et conséquence immédiate le
député désormais ex heller ne siégera
plus au sein du groupe majoritaire de
droite guillaume pelletier a fait part
de sa décision de démissionner de la
présidence du groupe upl c y et de
siéger désormais comme non inscrit son
choix de quitter le groupe upl c'est y
était le seul envisageable pour certains
conseillers départementaux du loir et
cher ce ralliement de guillaume
pelletier eric zemmour n'est pas une
surprise c'est un retour à ses racines
politiques après des débuts au front
national de la jeunesse puis
successivement chez bruno mégret
philippe de villiers enfin l'ump en 2009
pour la gauche la majorité
départementale a joué avec le feu
aujourd'hui l'extrême droite et présente
de fait aux contres et départementales
de loire et cher et la responsabilité
qui a fait rentrer l'extrême droite au
conseil départemental de loir et cher et
bien ce sont aussi celles et ceux qui
ont investi guillaume pelletier lors des
dernières élections départementales
désormais non inscrits guillaume
pelletier continuera-t-il de voter les
projets de la majorité une majorité déjà
courte à 16 contre 14 tenant grâce à
deux élus de gauche
contacté l'élu d'un pas donné suite à
nos demandes mais son entourage assure
qu'il continuera de soutenir l'ubs et
lci mais pour l'opposition centriste la
majorité est déjà fragilisée on avait
besoin de clarification et c'est une
bonne chose quelque part maintenant
reste à savoir si effectivement cette
assemblée départementale aura besoin de
l'extrême droite pour continuer à avoir
une majorité l'avenir politique de
guillaume pelletier s'inscrit-il encore
en loir et cher isolé au département et
dans sa circonscription aux prochaines
élections législatives tif de juin il
trouvera face à lui un candidat ait
l'air pas sûr que les électeurs du
canton de chambord lui pardonne son
revirement